a generation is obsessed with Napoleon
Dynamite do fans come up to you and
start imitating your Napoleon Dynamite
to your face right to my face yeah yeah
no yeah like anything that they come up
they they say the lines
normally I don't have to do it myself
because they'll like say something from
the point I'm like okay and they'll give
me your shots I'm like you saying it
yeah okay all right you like they'll
just start rattling off their favorite
lines and I leave duck around the corner
and because their eyes are closed all
time they don't even know you know let's
say you're making a phone call you're
ordering a pizza
you're on a sex hotline do you need a
urinal yeah do people recognize your
voice just without seeing you if you if
yeah you know not that I just leave
that's the number-one problem whenever
I'm around I luckily most people don't
recognize me because I'm uglier than the
character but my voice my voice oh no my
voice gives her away they're like turn
around like hey you know you're that guy
right I was playing xbox one time you
guys know Xbox Live way back in the day
and and I was playing with these guys
where you play with strangers online and
I was playing some game and they after
you know some like joking around kid and
this is way back right after the movie
came out so I didn't care like I wasn't
all like snooty like I am now you know
they they said dude you sound like that
guy in Napoleon Dynamite and I was like
look at my friend my boy like I am him I
think it was cool they're like no way so
they like proceeded to give me a quiz
like while we're like destroying each
other and to see if you could do it you
know no way that's no way you're him and
so they start like what's your wife's
name like I hope you don't know that
yeah where do you live but I was able to
pass the test and it's magical you
became here it was magical moment you I
have to ask you about this I saw this
photo it's a photo of you and and your
your your co-star in dynamite
Efrain Ramirez who plays Pedro you guys
went to the Giants Packer
playoff game what's going on here what
do you what are the two of you wearing
what is that uh enough about what we're
wearing it's more about how empty the
field is that at the end of the game and
we're all like in high spirits and
everybody was like get off the field you
losers and but yes those are the okay
I'm curious that you satisfied that I'm
much more interested in what you're
wearing I don't know what that is
that'll be a but it's the Forever Lazy
it's it's the updated version of the
Snuggie
it's the competitor to the Snuggie
competitors how we're different in this
note well we're the Snuggie is a blanket
with arms but you can't really do much
else you walk around they could still
fall off the Forever Lazy is a blanket
you step inside it's as if I'm it's like
a jumpsuit Wow yeah and it's also
because it has a trapdoor
so if you have to use and no doubt I did
my business that way why is there in the
stands so it's called the forever it's
called the Forever Lazy and you enjoy
this product I do okay as much as $99
for one of those
okay why don't you yeah why don't you
then that's a terrible infomercial we
just did pay as much as $99 I don't know